[Music]
following another choice tweet in a new
tell-all book a group of psychiatrists
are publicly warning now more than ever
that the president is dangerous and
urging that he be removed from access to
weapons these psychiatrists are
expressing a view that millions of
Americans share and millions reject and
claiming that their expertise as mental
health professionals as authority but
doesn't as a psychiatrist I say no they
have no greater insight into Trump's
behavior and thus his fitness for office
when they claim to they politicize our
profession his grandiosity and
impulsivity were evident during the
campaign and earlier there is baseline
features had his personality undergone
rapid deterioration affected his ability
to govern then the Cabinet and Congress
would likely ask psychiatrist for
diagnosis treatment options and a
prognosis in the course of invoking the
25th amendment to deprive him of his
powers but ultimately this is a
political process not a medical one what
everyone thinks of mr. Trump his actions
and words are on display for all to see
the public doesn't need experts to
interpret them should psychiatrists
comment publicly on the mental health of
the president let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI